we all now know about the Second
Amendment we hear about it all the time
it it it is a huge driver of our
politics on the right what people need
to know is that the Second Amendment
only recently became such a salient
Amendment here's the Second Amendment a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free State let me
repeat that a well-regulated militia
being necessary to the security of a
free State the right of the people to
keep and bear Arms shall not be
infringed well first of all what did
that mean the Second Amendment back in
the 1780s and 90's when when the
Constitution and its first amendments
were written it meant because the united
the new united states would have no
standing army that any armed defense of
the states or the united states would
depend on militia who would be mobilized
to fight the fights they needed to fight
so there's that another important fact
about the state of play when this
amendment was written was the nature of
of arms themselves of guns a really good
shooter could fire three or four rounds
a minute and that's a really good one
with these poorly aimed muskets and
early rifles they had so that was that
was what was being regulated it was oh
let's have a militia and they can use
these guns which were the state of the
art but compared to many many many
rounds per second firearms that we have
today were it's the same word but
virtually a different machine so the so
fast for slow forward for four centuries
the Second Amendment didn't really come
up people had guns they hunted not
everybody but that's what happens they
they they use them for
in rare cases but it wasn't a big deal
until starting in the 1960s when
suddenly in a matter of months in a few
years a president a presidential
candidate the great leader of African
America and freedom Martin Luther King
were killed and other other people
attacked by assassins suddenly it seemed
too reasonable people that oh we should
have some controls on on who can get
guns how easily so we enacted some very
modest regulations about registration
and and and and limiting certain kinds
of cheap weapons and so forth
and back then in the late 60s and even
in the early 70s the National Rifle
Association was was reasonable was fine
okay yeah you know they they they
negotiated these laws but they were okay
then as so many things were going
haywire in the national discourse um in
the in the late 70s the the National
Rifle Association and the the gun lobby
more generally went out of its mind to
be blunt and decided to be absolutist
that there would be no regulation of
guns and we would fight any regulation
of guns and moreover that was all driven
by a fantasy that the federal government
was about to confiscate all of our guns
that every individual had so suddenly
the Second Amendment became a thing that
that was that people were aware of and
that was driving this passionate fervent
political faction and the NRA by the way
changed its its motto from one about
safe sporting and so forth to quoting
the Second Amendment but still for a
while for twenty years the the the
courts did not weren't buying the this
idea that that the Second Amendment
meant
we could not regulate the ownership of
guns or the sales of guns and and by the
way we'd allowed Oh you can't buy a
machine gun no you can't have a
sawed-off shotgun that those things
happen over the course of the 20th
century nobody nobody said boo but
suddenly at the end of the 20th century
we had this ferocious and powerful
faction interpreting the Second
Amendment in a new way interpreting the
Second Amendment in a new way that the
retired Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court in the 90s after he retired Warren
burger a Republican put in place by a
Republican president said this is a
fraud that people like the NRA are
committing this is not what the second
Second Amendment means it's it's it's
it's a fraud he said but they kept at it
and and it became more and more
respectable this idea that that the
Second Amendment was was was was
absolute and and and applied to
individuals who weren't members of the
National Guard or any other
well-regulated militia and finally in
2008 2010 in two decisive definitive
absolute decisions the Supreme Court
decided this new interpretation of the
Second Amendment that had not existed in
in respectable legal circles twenty
years earlier was the was the law is
what the Constitution meant so that's
now what our Constitution means and I
think so as a result any I think really
meaningful regulation of the ownership
of guns at this point is a political
fantasy as a result ironically of of the
Second Amendment
absolutists and Andry interpreters and
revisionists and fantasies having
imposed their interpretation of of the
Second Amendment on all of us
you